one of the most fundamental aspects of
being human is our innate daily Reliance
on food to survive the food we eat of
course delivers essential nutrients to
our bodies it gives us the energy to
perform our daily tasks and it can also
unite people of every cultural
background around this Universal need
that we all share but no matter what
your dietary restrictions may be or what
your preferences are I think we can all
agree that not all food is created equal
16 years ago I suffered a health scare
and became motivated for the very first
time to give up junk food and attempt to
eat healthier and that Journey led to a
profound and surprising discovery which
is that the more whole plant Foods
predominated my plate the better I felt
and the better I performed
this Epiphany led me to adopting a 100
plant-based diet which has served me
better than well for the past 16 years
it's powered me through some of the
world's most grueling endurance
challenges and it continues to motivate
me to evangelize its many benefits all
of which brings us to today
last year and a half we here at the
podcast have been doing quarterly
episodes around a singular theme that we
characterize and offer up as a master
class for example in past episodes of
this series we've covered addiction
we've talked about mental health that
gut microbiome spirituality and
Longevity but today we're going to turn
our attention to plant-based nutrition
and we're going to begin today's master
class with the plant power doctor
herself Dr Gemma Newman Gemma is a
senior partner at a family medical
practice in the UK where as part of our
practice she provides evidence-based
nutrition and lifestyle advice to her
patients in this first clip Gemma helps
us answer tough questions like how could
we choose a lifestyle that is typically
not widely socially accepted and what is
the right mindset in a relationship when
one partner chooses to be plant-based
and the other does not Dr Newman is
uniquely Suited it to help answer these
questions because she herself
reluctantly came around to a plant-based
lifestyle later in life and in her
medical practice so here we go this is
me and Dr Gemma Newman
perhaps even the bigger issue in
stumbling block is really the social
issue like people get all up in their
heads about what other people are going
to think about them what's going to
happen when they go to Susie and Dave's
you know dinner party and they don't
want to make a fuss or I have to go on
vacation with my neighbors and you know
it's just going to be too problematic
and people like relinquish their
boundaries or you know are are just too
afraid to to stand up for themselves or
to like make that conscious choice
because they don't want to be difficult
yeah I can totally relate to that
because that was my instinct first of
all when I started on this journey my
main thought was oh this is going to be
so awkward for everybody people are
going to think this is so strange you
know it's I think as social creatures
it's one of the main considerations that
a lot of people have
um and
I guess it comes down to
living in alignment with the things that
you most want
um do you most want to be somebody that
pleases others
do you most want to be somebody that
lives in alignment with things that are
important to you are those things one
and the same
if you can have a conversation with
yourself around the values that you're
living by
it becomes much easier to then make
conscious choices that are in alignment
to those values so
I would actually encourage everybody to
have this conversation with their loved
ones or even just with themselves they
could write it down in a journal write
down their top values in life and how
their food choices can relate to those
values and then it becomes a lot easier
because you're taking away a lot of the
extra choices that you're having to make
or these social situations that you're
having to navigate because you are
consciously living in alignment with the
things that matter so if it matters to
you to minimize your risk of heart
disease because you have a relative that
died young you want to see your children
grow up then you write that down and you
find ways to make it work within that
kind of framework if you like your
values framework
if Animal Compassion is important to you
it's probably a lot easier because
you've already made that decision for
another outside purpose it's something
that's outside of yourself and perhaps
the same can be true for someone that
cares deeply about the environment and
the planet they've already made that
decision based on a value that's so
strong to them that it Max actually
makes it a little bit easier stick to I
think health
overall is probably one of the first
ways people go towards plant-based
nutrition but it's also one of the
hardest ways to stick with it if that's
your only goal because it's quite
self-focused whereas if you can focus on
something outside of self then it
potentially could make those choices a
lot easier either environmental health
or Animal Compassion or reasons to stay
healthy for others
it tends to be in my experience ways
that make it stick a lot more yeah
that's that's a really good way of
thinking about it one of the questions
that I get all the time I'm sure you do
as well is I want to do this but my
partner doesn't want any part of it and
you began this journey Richard was doing
it ahead of you two different dinners
meals Etc but for a lot of couples that
becomes very problematic especially when
those values might come into conflict
with each other yes you're so right and
I think my advice from that being the
partner that was most reluctant perhaps
I can speak to this more
um is the idea that what I needed was
um was patience and time and sometimes
people will never come around sometimes
the people you love the most will never
want to do the things that are important
to you when it comes to diet and
I think that taking away that
expectation is important because when
you start to expect things of other
people that's where you can start to
become very unhappy you know you have it
builds kind of criticism in your mind it
builds comparison uh it builds
expectation and that can be quite toxic
for your relationship
so my best advice is just to do the
thing that's making you happy do the
thing that brings you in alignment with
who you want to be and show your partner
through your actions how much happier
how much healthier and how much more
abundant you feel in your life and then
if they want to come along for the ride
they can right but you have to be
detached from that expectation otherwise
you're going to be vibing them all the
time and then that piousness creeps up
and that just becomes a disaster exactly
you've got to let that go
even if it's in the back well if I keep
doing this they'll eventually come
around oh it's no no you gotta like get
rid of that I I do think that that's
probably the best way for you to sustain
a healthy relationship with the people
that you love the most and it's hard
because often the people you love the
most may you feel need it the most
especially if they have a health
condition that could benefit from doing
that but you have to let it go because
it's not your life it's their life I
mean that's advice for this particular
scenario but for for you know a zillion
others exactly like in terms of like
partnership Dynamics yeah and in a
partnership you will often have
expectations of a partner that are
unspoken and that could be true for any
kind of scenario
um and that's not to say that you
shouldn't communicate the things that
are important to you of course you
should but it's the expectation that is
attached to that which I think can
become very negative in in the
relationship so letting go of the
expectations of your partner is probably
the key to a happier life in all sorts
of ways did Richard do that yeah he was
very patient with me
but that brings up an important issue
which is
you know somebody who's listening to
this or watching it is thinking well my
life is just going to become infinitely
more complicated it means like we're
gonna have to prepare two different
meals I'm gonna have to spend all this
time in the kitchen I'm gonna have to
plan out everything in advance it's
probably going to be expensive and
suddenly my life which was kind of going
along pretty good suddenly gets hijacked
by this new lifestyle habit that is
going to commandeer all my time energy
and money yeah and those are
very valid concerns and I guess what I'd
say to that person is you have to find
the thing that
helps you know
um where you're going for the future I
think a lot of the time we kind of Coast
through and we do things because they
are the path of least resistance
and
sometimes a path of least resistance is
a great path and it works and
everything's going well but sometimes
over the course of maybe weeks months to
years we start to notice actually this
isn't really working for me anymore you
know although this is the easier route
I'm not feeling this I either don't feel
healthy or there's something niggling me
in in my conscience about things I want
to do differently
and sometimes changes do require a
certain amount of Forward Thinking so
the person who's sticking that seed into
the soil right now and getting ready to
water it but doesn't know how to water
it like how do you think about the the
early phases of this like I'm somebody
who went all in that's just my
personality type I recognize most people
aren't like that uh I suspect you're
somebody who would counsel people to
make tiny changes Master them like how
do you get somebody engaged in this and
give them some actionable advice about
how to begin in a very practical manner
so number one is literally write down
the foods that you buy in your weekly
Shop number two is write down all the
foods that you make with those
ingredients and if you can find one meal
a week that you'd like to have more
plants in then that can be your first
step it's literally just cook one meal a
week that is plant-based and see how you
feel
and then if that works for you then you
can cook another one
and then maybe cook another one there's
always a starting point for everybody if
you're somebody that just eats takeout
then you know what for you the best
thing would be perhaps just to start
with one home-cooked meal a week rather
than trying to change everything just
cook one meal at home rather than having
all meals take out
um for my elderly patient who was just
eating like small ready meals from the
supermarket switched to a plant-based
one and see how you feel see if it
changes your health over time so it's
just it is for a lot of people about
those baby steps yeah
um for others like you they jump in and
they'll get started and they'll figure
it out along the way and they'll enjoy
that process and that's great but for
most people it's just little steps and
you know there was research by B.J Fogg
to show that only one like one change is
enough to then start changing Shifting
the identity and then sort of adding in
something new after that so yeah just
one thing one thing is all you need to
do
it's one thing to go vegan it's another
thing to go strictly Whole Food
plant-based and then optimizing your
plant-based diet for things like Health
longevity and athletic prowess is yet
another thing altogether
so let's better understand this and to
do that we should talk to an expert
shouldn't we about the early stages of
your adoption of this lifestyle some of
the things that you should be made aware
of that you should focus on and you
should include in this adaptation to
this new way of eating and living so to
do that we're going to talk to the
brilliant Simon Hill my friend who is a
nutrition science expert he's an author
a restaurateur he is a fellow podcaster
just a fountain of practical knowledge
that can benefit the newly reformed as
well as the more seasoned plant-based
Advocate Among Us
so let's say Okay Simon I've been eating
a plant-based diet for six months or a
year how do I know I'm doing it right
what are some of the common
um things that trip people up or where
they go astray before they have kind of
the full you know encyclopedic knowledge
of how to do this properly
there's probably two or three main
things that I've identified anyway in in
working with many people who are going
through this and also through my own
experience and and talking to people
like you I think the first is
understanding when you're minimizing or
removing these animal foods that we have
grown accustomed to eating all the time
what do you replace them with because
there's a lot of different options
everything from black beans and lentils
to very processed uh vegan foods the
second would be understanding the
difference between an animal-based diet
and a plant-based diet in terms of
calorie density
so animal foods are typically much more
calorie dense and
therefore if you're wanting to eat the
similar number of calories your plate
needs to look fuller right when it's
plant-based food I mean that's a pretty
common thing that you hear like oh I
tried it but I was starving all the time
yes and that is something that I
personally experienced so as I was
making these changes I was not fully
cognizant of the differences in calorie
density and I I was experiencing in in
the very beginning of my transition a
little drop in energy and I I was
doubting whether the plant-based Foods
were working for me and really it was
just that I was not consuming enough
overall calories
so understanding what to replace animal
foods with calorie density and then the
third I'd say is having a general
awareness of specific nutrients of focus
so all diets whether it's an omnivorous
diet or a plant-based diet need to be
appropriately planned or they can fall
short and you know if we look around
at our current sort of state of health
the the omnivorous diets not really
serving us that well it has a number of
holes and gaps and while a plant-based
diet can really improve your overall
disease risk profile and we spoke a lot
about that in terms of you know shifting
these biomarkers in a favorable
Direction your cholesterol your blood
glucose control
inflammation blood pressure and lower
your risk of these chronic diseases that
are plaguing our society
at the same time there are a few
nutrients that you need to be aware of
so that you are getting them in the the
required amounts to not just prevent
your risk of these chronic diseases long
term but to really optimize yourself and
and feel at your best in your day-to-day
so the obvious next question being what
are those nutrients yeah uh so I I call
these nutrients of focus
and I think that's a positive spin on
nutrients of concern
and I just I want people I want to draw
people's attention to them in the book I
write about eight of these and some of
these are quite easy to get through your
diet and or fortified foods and then
others are best access through a
supplement
so as a list these are vitamin B12
vitamin D
omega-3 fatty acids
iodine iron calcium zinc and selenium
right
so given that
a skeptic would say well if I have to
pay extra close attention to these
things or I have to go outside of my
food that I'm consuming and supplement
then this must be a deficient diet by
definition
I think we need to
zoom out a little bit and understand
that nutritional gaps are nothing new
and it's the very reason that folate and
iodine have been used throughout the
food system fortifying foods to prevent
iodine deficiency and folate deficiency
in the general public so this idea of
fortification or supplements is nothing
new and
lots of those nutrients I just reeled
off like zinc selenium iron calcium you
can easily access them through your diet
you don't need to supplement those it's
just a matter of understanding what
foods do you want to be incorporating in
your diet regularly and for example if
you're choosing a plant-based milk to
swap out Dairy which is rich in calcium
what should you be looking for
and what we should be worried most about
is heart health outcomes so I I have
nothing against a diet that includes
some supplementation if that means the
best outcomes for beer for myself or or
anyone that I'm working with and and
that is what the data suggests if you
want to move down this path of very
plant Rich plant predominant diets or
even plants exclusive
to lower your your risk of chronic
disease
then taking some of these supplements is
going to allow you to do that in a more
optimal manner right
an early Advocate and practitioner of
preventative medicine long before it was
trendy Dr Dean ornish is an absolute
legend in the plant-based nutrition
movement for his groundbreaking work and
the holistic prevention and reversal of
chronic lifestyle diseases his vast
experience and deep wisdom are perfect
primers for those curious about the
benefits of a whole food plant-based
lifestyle and he's here today so let's
hear from him
well first of all unfortunately because
I debated Dr Atkins so many times and he
was the low carb guy I got pegged as a
low fat guy our program has never just
been about fat it's really about a Whole
Foods plant-based diet that's low in fat
and sugar and Stress Management moderate
exercise and what we call social support
which is really love and intimacy or eat
well move more stress less love more you
know that's it
um but even the idea of fat the problem
was number one you know people say oh
Americans have been totally less fat you
know we're fatter than ever low-fat is
dead it's all sugar but we may have been
told to eat less fat but I went to the
U.S department of Agriculture database
because they keep track of the entire
food supply not what people say they're
eating but what they're actually eating
and oftentimes there's a big discrepancy
and what we found is that in every
decade since 1950 we may have been told
to eat less fat but we're eating a lot
more fat 67 percent more fat more sugar
more meat and more calories more of
everything more of everything so not
surprising we're fat not because reading
too little fat but because we're eating
too much of everything yeah so the idea
is that that it's not that the low-fat
thing didn't work it's that people
didn't actually do it and the other
thing is besides getting more fat is
people when they did replace fat they
would replace it with sugar so you have
the snack well cookies and you know the
Entenmann's cakes and things like that
and that's not a good choice right but I
think if you actually look at all of the
data there's more evidence than ever
that an optimal diet is low in fat and
low in sugar it's predominantly fruits
vegetables whole grains legumes soy
products in their natural forms and
we've been doing studies for 40 years so
you know having been in all these
different diet Wars and diet debates I
said you know look I'm done you know we
we've done every study that we've done
has shown that these same lifestyle
changes can reverse heart disease we're
able to show that for the first time
type 2 diabetes high blood pressure high
cholesterol obesity we're doing the
other first randomized trial now to see
if we can actually reverse Alzheimer's
disease we found that when you change
your lifestyle it changes your genes you
know hundreds of genes over 500 genes in
three months turning on the good genes
turning off the Bad genes in just three
months we found that in a study we did
that we published that with Craig Venter
who first decoded the human genome right
we did a study with Elizabeth Blackburn
it got the Nobel Prize for discovering
telomeresians of our chromosomes that
regulate how long we live we've shown
for the first time that in just three
months we can increase telomerase the
enzyme that repairs and lengthens
telomeres by 30 percent
and over a five-year period we showed
again for the first time we can actually
lengthen telomeres in a sense reversing
aging at a cellular level so the more
diseases we study and the more
underlying mechanisms we look at the
more reasons we have to explain why
these simple changes are so powerful and
how quickly people can get better these
things are so much more Dynamic than we
once realized that when you eat this way
your brain gets more blood flow you can
actually grow so many new brain neurons
in just a few weeks your brain gets
bigger in particular those parts of your
brain like the hippocampus that control
memory that you want to get bigger you
know when people get older they say like
you know what was where do I leave my
keys and what was that person's name a
lot of that's reversible your skin gets
more blood so you don't age as quickly
your heart gets more blood we found you
can reverse heart disease or sexual
organs get more blood flow and when
people realize that it's not just about
living longer it's about feeling better
and improving the quality of life it
really reframes that debate from you
know fear of dying which is not
sustainable to Joy of living and feeling
good and pleasure which really are right
what is the difference between mean how
the body metabolizes the animal protein
versus plant protein or is it like the
saturated fat and cholesterol that
generally is conjoined with the intake
of animal protein well animal protein is
is harmful and plant-based protein is
not only not harmful it's actually
protective there are literally hundreds
of thousands of substances and fruits
and vegetables and whole grains and
legumes and soy products that have any
cancer anti-hard disease and anti-aging
properties things like phytochemicals
bioflavonoids carotenoids retinols
isofibones genosine lycopene there's a
whole alphabet soup of these things and
where do you find them with few
exceptions you find them in in
plant-based Foods the animal-based foods
besides being high in saturated fat and
dietary I mean you only get dietary
cholesterol in animal products is the
animal protein itself is inflammatory
and in our new book part of what the
this kind of unifying theory that we're
putting together for the first time is
why is it that these same lifestyle
changes are so powerful the more
diseases we study the more underlying
mechanisms we look at the more reasons
we have to explain why these changes are
so powerful and it's because although we
tend to think of heart disease as being
different than diabetes different than
prostate cancer and different than
Alzheimer's disease and so on the
radical idea here is this unifying
theory is that they're not they're
different expressions of the same
underlying disorders the mechanisms like
chronic inflammation oxidative stress
over some stimulation of the sympathetic
nervous system changes in the microbiome
changes in as we've been talking about
in gene expression and telomeres and
angiogenesis and each of these
mechanisms in turn is affected by what
we eat how we respond to stress how much
exercise we get and how much love and
support we have and so seen in this
larger context the animal protein
activates all of these different
mechanisms in negative ways which is
what makes it harmful in an independent
of the fact that it's also high in
saturated fat dietary cholesterol and
other things like that you know it's
like people say oh I'm not going to get
enough protein on a plant-based diet and
you said well ask Mr elephant you know
that's uh or that ask Rich for holding I
mean you're a living example of what can
be done on a plant-based diet I mean
most most guys would be uh happy to do
half of what you can do
my next guest may not have invented the
whole food plant-based diet but he's
certainly the Regal line of the movement
he's a guy who pioneered it from Fringe
acceptance all the way to widespread
mainstream adoption of course I can only
be referring to the one the only T Colin
Campbell the man best known for writing
an incredible book called The China
Study which to date is one of the most
important groundbreaking massively
best-selling books ever written on
health and nutrition this is excerpted
from a conversation we recorded many
years ago so I'm very excited and proud
to resurface this clip this excerpt
between me and T Colin Campbell on the
power of a plant-based diet
it really coming back to the question of
concerning animal protein I mean that
had been a lifelong or career-long
question because we were able to in the
prior studies we were able to show that
we could turn on and turn off cancer
just simply by feeding of all things the
protein of cow's milk which brought me
back to the dairy farm in a sense and
that was very provocative to say the
least and I think it's you know there
might be a perspective out there that
you were out to you know sort of prove
to establish an objective that you
already believed in but you're coming
from this dairy farm background and it
had been your whole you know the the
conviction of your entire upbringing
that you know the hook does a body good
that this is the perfect food right so
where did you start to begin to see kind
of cracks in the in the firmament of
that concept was the initial observation
I think we did was the the the there
were some Indian researchers who had
done some Laboratory animal sledges that
showed that at the time that I was in
the Philippines and but they didn't
believe what they got it was published
in obscure Journal but I kind of
believed that because it was consistent
with what I was seeing with the children
and so as we went into that research we
looked at it in Great depth and I had
become convinced you know by that time
we we did it so many different ways that
animal protein actually increases cancer
risk period
and so I was really interested to know
in The China Study where there was any
evidence for that
uh and my bias was to find the opposite
right really was I mean if I if I had a
Prejudice and that's a very important
point you know I think that that you
weren't out to you know sort of be on
this Crusade uh to uh you know
with this foregone conclusion that you
already had in your mind you went out
and you surveyed a gigantic population
of people across innumerable variables
and and remained open-minded and I to
take what you just said hopeful that
maybe it might prove the opposite that's
right absolutely I
I was always kind of swimming Upstream
against my own sort of Prior prejudices
but finally the evidence was
overwhelming
with respect to for starters was the
effect of animal protein on encouraging
the development of cancers if you will
but then there were other questions that
arose too at the same time and always
having this doubt you know about the
significance of this we had asked I
would want to ask broader questions what
if we eat animal protein containing
foods what about all the other nutrients
that come along with it what's happening
there do they cancel each other so we
started investigating all the nutrients
of the cancers all the diseases and the
more that I looked the more consistent
became the data everything seemed to all
the nutrients in animal-based Foods as
opposed to all the nutrients and
plant-based Foods they seem to be doing
opposite things and and their activities
were sort of mutually supportive
you know the biochemical physiological
level so the story became for me even
ever more impressive
was uh but it was always coming from a
position in my case and it says someone
was trying to disprove right you know
what I had observed and this is this is
a a landmark Discovery right this is
this had never been sort of established
or presumed or even conjured by anyone
prior to you
it's an interesting question and I'll
come in just a minute but yes when we
were doing all the research in the
laboratory and because of my skepticism
about a lot of things what we ended up
discovering were a lot of fundamental
ideas that were against the rules
against what I was teaching against what
was in the books such as well for
example turning cancer on and off by
nutritional means I mean that was a big
deal
and that it turned out we didn't do it
just with protein and liver cancer we
also did it with dietary fat and
pancreatic cancer and things like this
so that that phenomenon of thinking
about the causation of cancer and later
other diseases as a result of Simply
modifying you know nutrient intake and
and the idea of actually reversing
disease right it's the turning over
reversing disease yeah and and cancer I
thought this is incredible
and so we're already learning other
things too like
um that the relationship between
nutrition and genes a lot of people
think and a lot of people still think
that somehow genes
predetermine whether or not we're going
to get a certain kind of disease and
what we are showing no it's not the case
we can have the genes to cause it to
start the initiation of events
but that we can control it by
nutritional means big thing another one
sort of principle like if you will an a
like protein it causes cancer let's say
for starters one of the things that I
was really being pushed to do to prove
my point was to find what the mechanism
was you know which enzyme was this was
that and so we started looking for the
mechanisms and it had a series of PhD
students to spending four or five years
like each of them looking at a mechanism
and it turned out there is no such thing
so that was another myth that I was all
of a sudden running across too and so a
lot of the things that we we learned
really were I think the result of my
skepticism
I feel like most people want to eat
better they want to improve their diets
absolutely have you heard of it I've
heard of it this trips up so many people
we thought hey we know a couple things
about how to do this a few so we created
this thing called the plant power meal
planner that is this beautiful offering
whereby you gain access to literally
thousands of plant-based recipes that
you can totally customize based upon
your preferences your allergies your
peccadillos it integrates with grocery
delivery so all the ingredients that you
need get shipped right to your door so
you can make the stuff that you've
pre-selected and we all could use a
little inspiration and support when
preparing meals for our families in our
busy lives so we hope you join us no
matter what your eating style is we have
our arms open wide and we've saved you a
space at our family table to join us in
eating more healthy vibrant plant-based
meals so if you want to learn more if
you want to go on this exploration
that's been so nourishing to Julie and I
I would encourage you to visit meals dot
richroll.com
[Laughter]
who's next my friend Dr Michael Greger
is next that's who Dr Greger for those
that don't know is one of the preeminent
Authorities on the plant-based lifestyle
and plant-based nutrition he's the man
behind the nutrition facts website which
is an incredibly robust resource for
searching for the latest most up-to-date
information on a vast spectrum of
medical nutritional and lifestyle topics
he's also the wildly best-selling author
of books including how not to die and
how not to diet he is an incredible
Communicator of nutritional information
I love him to death so here is a clip
between me and Dr Michael Greger
what is a day in your personal life with
food like how do you make it work well
on the right well again
yeah and how do you deal with the
airports and all of that yeah airport
food courts yeah well look it's getting
easier now you can get like brown rice
in an airport I mean that's great like
these like you know fast casual places
like I you know things you never expect
to see before and look there's you know
I've grown better you know if I can you
know land someplace and find Whole Foods
and have a hot bar and I can grab some
food and you know first few days I have
snacks and then slowly it's all gone you
know what I've been doing recently is I
we tell the organizers you got to bring
me food you know I mean there's only so
many marketers in the rider there's only
so many sweet potatoes
the guy with the crazy Rider right right
what does he think that's Van Halen not
only no green M M's no M M's buried it's
all right
um and so right and so look I you know I
need to I yeah and typically I don't
even have time even if I could I mean
right even if there's healthy food
around here I am Southern California I
can get healthy food but I don't have
time I mean it's just and on the rare
days that you're at home oh now then
once I have control over my life how
excited you are and no that's a
beautiful thing I well I mean I just
yeah this is my first day of this this
few weeks stint and so I'm feeling the
the leaving home thing it was it was it
was hard to get up this morning but
um yeah then I can eat this beautiful
diet oh my and it's like it's almost
it's like a it's like a it's like a game
like how healthy can I get I mean it's
really
um and uh and you know what helped so I
do a lot of food delivery like Whole
Foods delivery and then then you're not
even tempted to buy junk because it's
not in front of you grab and so it's
like everything I eat so my house just
has healthy food and so if you get
hungry enough you're gonna eat an apple
right I mean there's nothing you will
eventually eat that apple right and so
with only healthy stuff
you know I can I can build up my my
healthy immune system a healthy choice
the uh the the most convenient right oh
yeah I could go out in the in the in the
Philadelphia winter and bike someplace
to get something to bike to the donut
shop but so much easier when I have a
fridge full of yummy food and do you
prepare stuff ahead of time I do a lot
of batch cooking yeah yeah yeah
um particularly now I'm doing a lot of
this this Prebiotic mix I talked about
my uh when I in studying the improving
your uh microbiome for the new Big
microbiome chapter in the in the diet
book
um and just learning how again how
important microbiome is and where the
most concentrated source of prebiotics
and so I I discovered sorghum for the
first time discovered all these weird
millets that I had no idea that have
poorly digested starch and so they are
fed to animals but poorly digestive
starch is exactly what we want because
it's poorly digested in our small
intestine makes it down to our lower
intestine where our good gut bugs can
have a bounty have prebiotics and that
has all those knock-on benefits and so
that's the kind of thing where I just
instant pot a huge amount and just you
know Tupperware in the fridge
um and you know take out one every day
since it's over and you know so I always
have uh always have my intact grains and
a whole bunch of wonderful black lentils
and then it's a matter of just getting
Greens in the house what else did you
learn about the gut uh the gut biome and
and prepping for this what's neat is now
we have these Interventional trials so
we've always known you uh you can so
flashback a few years ago it was a black
hole almost no pun intended where
because most gut bugs are actually
unculturable in laboratory conditions
like we can't grow them outside of the
human colon we don't know without gas or
we don't know and so we have black bike
we had no idea what was going on there
until we had genetic fingerprinting
techniques and also and for the first
time we'd be like oh okay we can
actually track people's microbiome over
time compare people's different
microbiomes and we can correlate
diseases with
um with different uh bugs in our gut and
change people's diets change the
microbiome see the beneficial or adverse
effects but that's the problem if you
improve someone's diet all of a sudden
you give people lots of whole grains and
legumes being splurpy chickpeas and
lentils lots of prebiotics they get
these beneficial changes in their
microbiome and also and they have
amazing health benefits uh yeah but you
just fed them a whole bunch of healthy
food how do we know microbiome has
anything to do with it that's where
fecal transplants come along right then
we can prove it's the microbiome because
we can take those gut bubs and put it
into somebody who's continuously the
crappy diet and see if we can get those
same metabolic benefits and that's what
we're saying so we're seeing
um yeah so you know someone gets a fecal
transplant for someone who's overweight
all of a sudden they start packing on
pounds eating the same food
um or there's that's crazy mental health
changes
um all sorts of crazy things
um and and then we can prove it's the
gut bug now what happens is of course
it's temporary because right you you
infuse the gut bugs but then you keep
starving them by not eating any fiber
and then they die away but you see
initially those same benefits of course
you got to feed those bugs and they're
going to die off but but so so what went
from a from a correlation science now we
have a causation science
um and it's just fascinating that we can
transfer the benefits of healthy diets
so so I mean so the the black market
Rich Roll stool you could I mean you
know the the the the the the the I mean
yeah start selling that [ __ ] it's
exactly I mean who wouldn't pay it is it
is fascinating I mean the links to
Cravings as well like the nature of the
gut Flora impacts the foods that you
create yeah yeah yeah yeah and it it
also I think is is
because it's so complex that it's Rife
for confusion and people kind of making
claims about what you should and you
shouldn't do that we don't necessarily
have the ability to really back up at
this point particularly this kind of
personalized nutrition like people all
the time are sending me things my I sent
my stool sample in to this company and
gave me back a thing and said I should
be eating this and I shouldn't be eating
this we don't have that because it does
not same thing with DNA testing right
people that get back there their genome
and say oh well I you know I'm whatever
I shouldn't be eating the Xbox we don't
have that kind of
um but is it true we should be eating
fermented foods and we should be eating
you know nutritionally a variety of
nutritionally dense foods to be kind of
seeding that that gut Flora with a
diversity of of of bacteria so it's the
three right so it's prebiotics
probiotics and polyphenols which are
these kind of attempt to be brightly
colored pigments and fruits and
vegetables these are kind of the three
uh the three things that benefited good
microbiome and you can use all three of
them or just two of them I mean the
problem with probiotics is you take them
and then they just die off you don't
continue to eat healthy and so if you
just have like antibiotic Associated
diarrhea or something you wipe out your
bugs then I see a therapeutic roll of
something like probiotics but otherwise
taking probiotics is useless because
they'll just die off if you put them in
the same environment that didn't grow
good gut bugs in the first place putting
in some good acid office they're just
going to die off because you're not
feeding the establas because good gut
bugs are by definition fiber feeders
resistant starch eaters these are I mean
that's that that's what makes good gut
bugs grow and so what we really need is
we just need to feed our good gut bugs
pre-box and people are like oh I eat so
many fruits and vegetables but let's
realize fruits and vegetables are almost
all water like you know uh fruits or
like 80 water or some water resist
vegetables 90 95 water they're water in
vegetable form not actually a lot of
fiber you can actually have a pretty
deficient fiber deficient diet if you're
not including whole grains and legumes
some of these drier Foods into your
daily diet wow
what can we learn from one of the
leading weight loss surgeons in the
country well next up is Dr Garth Davis
Garth is a friend he's a multiple
podcast guest he's the author of an
Incredible Book you should all read
called protein a holic and somebody who
is well steeped in the medical
literature of countless studies the
conclusions drawn from his in-depth
reading and direct surgical practice
experience are that
if we want to prevent obesity and
disease if we want to attain and
maintain ideal weight management and if
we want to ultimately achieve true
Optimal Health and long-term Wellness
we're going to need to embrace our inner
herbivore
so I think in one of your I think it was
in your talk that I saw recently you
said something like uh you know only
three percent of the population is
protein deficient and but oh I would say
lesson but like but like 97 of the
population is fiber deficient and what
we should be talking about is fiber and
not protein right right when you look at
they came out the new and Haynes data
and what do we actually eat in this
country no one's protein deficient you
gotta understand the RDA well a protein
deficiency would be starvation it would
be starting like core sugars yeah
exactly you'd have to you would have to
not be eating you'd have to be eating
less than a thousand calories to
probably get it
um and so we just don't see that
um so the RDA when they set up their
recommendation for protein requirements
they based it on some nitrogen balance
studies and all this kind of stuff and
they came up with a figure
like for men 56 grams and for women 44
grams or 42 grams and that figure is
actually an optimal amount it's not a
minimal amount I think people think
that's the lowest amount that I should
get it's actually the optimal amount
based on those studies probably you
would do fine with 30 grams of protein
but they just want to make sure that
everybody was covered
now we eat 70 to 100 sometimes 130 grams
of protein a day so we're way over the
optimal amount we're way in excess and
when all these studies where they've
gone and interview people the one thing
everyone's looking for is even more
protein to make it's crazy yet we eat
unbelievably low amounts of fiber and
there there are not a lot of good
studies that show that there's long-term
health and eating a lot of protein
there's tons of good studies tons and
tons showing eating a lot of fiber is
good for you long term and we are
unbelievable we are in a mass deficit of
fiber and yet no one's talking about
that because it's not just the fiber
it's what the fiber is you know there's
no fiber in the animal products there's
only fiber in the plant right but if you
forget just forget about protein and
let's shift all of that Focus that you
had on protein and put it on fiber and
then see what would happen yeah my
message would be it's almost impossible
not to get enough protein no matter what
you're eating that's number one number
two eating more protein will make you
sick eventually
um and number three eating more plants
is really like finding a fountain of
youth makes you it's not just because
people say oh I don't care if I live you
know 10 years longer if you know I have
to eat that crap the food's delicious
it's just your whole taste buds change
that's the thing I think people miss or
don't get they don't and they can't
imagine that they'll actually get to a
place where they will desire or crave
healthy foods yeah I have patients say
to me I wish I had your willpowered to
me it's not willpower it's not willpower
for me to eat a kale salad I crave a
kale salad but I used to crave a double
cheeseburger and you could change that I
could talk about how I change that with
patients but you could change this
thought process and you could change
your taste and everybody who goes
through it I get this you know blessing
you know all these people online yakking
about this and that and they've never
treated a patient I get to sit across
from a patient actually see these
changes and the changes are amazing the
way people feel the way they look what
they're doing in their life it's it's
really rewarding and when I think about
how many people in this world could
benefit if we just got rid of this idea
of protein and went to the idea of you
know Whole Foods fruits vegetables beans
it would really change the health of the
country the health of the environment
and uh and and have so many other
benefits out there I personally never
count ever never count I never think to
myself I need to get protein I'll make a
post-workout Shake where I will throw in
some hemp seeds and I'll get some
protein there I eat nuts during the day
I'll get protein there I ate a lot of
beans
and I'm only getting stronger and faster
I mean is there an argument to be made
that uh
that the protein from animal flesh is
qualitatively different from the protein
from plants in other words is an amino
acid an amino acid irrespective of where
it comes from or is the Matrix and which
it's delivered to your body does that
make a difference in terms in terms of
how you metabolize it the
bioavailability and all of that
yeah you know um you bring up a good
point but um the studies that have shown
that bioavailability of plant-based
proteins is excellent
um like for instance plant-based
proteins are much higher in glutamic
acid now glutamic acid is fantastic for
lowering blood pressure which might be
part of the reason plants are so good
with lemon pressure
meat based proteins are higher in
branched chain amino acids now if you're
a bodybuilder this is good for several
reasons it increases igf-1 igf-1 is a
growth hormone so it's a growth hormone
you're going to grow your muscles
number two
um
there are definitely things like leucine
definitely stimulate muscle protein
synthesis and so if your bodybuilder you
want to stimulate muscle protein
synthesis but here's the catch we know
from aging studies and from cancer
studies that having a high igf-1 and
high leucine actually leads to premature
aging and cellular death and cancer
so what I'm seeing from these
bodybuilding protocols that may in fact
make bodybuilder have more muscle may
make them unhealthier in the long term I
mean it's impossible to do a good study
on it but if you look at old
bodybuilders they all have a scar down
the middle of their chest they've all
had heart surgery now is that the high
protein diets or is it the steroids you
know I can't differentiate that and tell
you that
um definitely a heavy animal protein
diet is associated with heart disease
definitely is associated with high blood
pressure and it's definitely associated
with a shorter length of life and the
interesting thing about the longevity
studies is we talked about taking out
confounding factors
if you take out a lot of confounding
factors you get to the point where
you're almost taking away a correlation
and yet after really rigorous
statistical analysis there's still a
finding that if you eat a plant-based
diet or if you eat less meat you live
longer
after a lifetime what do seasoned
medical doctors have to say to incoming
doctors as they pass through their
medical training well Dr Michael Clapper
personifies that question Dr Clapper is
a renowned physician who spent his years
treating diseases that he felt were
reversible or completely avoidable but
rather than impacting single patients at
a time he shifted gears and went
directly to the medical schools to
lecture incoming Physicians on the
virtue of food as medicine
here is Dr Clapper
over the course of your uh many decade
career I'm sure you've seen diet Trends
and fats come and go and you know it's
interesting to see what sticks and what
doesn't and what passes I'm sure you've
seen it all
um
and right now we're in a moment where we
are seeing you know the explosion of
interest in plant-based diets and the
science that backs it up in lockstep
with that though there's also a very you
know strident growing movement around
low carb eating and the keto diet and so
I'm sure these questions come up all the
time especially with these students and
just in general so how do you kind of
think about that and how do you
communicate around those other protocols
and what is your perspective on that oh
my uh there's a another show at itself
plenty of times good okay well I mean
this is like you know listen there's a
lot of plant-based people that listen to
the show but there's people that are on
different kinds of diets absolutely and
I think the reason I'm asking you this
question is you know for even a very
well educated motivated listener or just
consumer in general they go online or
they you know read whatever's happening
and they see the stuff about plant-based
but they also see the stuff about keto
and low carb and it's confusing even if
you're you know going to PubMed and and
reading abstracts which almost no one
does it's still confusing right there's
science to support different
perspectives and it's all very
disorienting and so I'm always trying to
drive people towards you know what is
common sense here where you know what
are the facts really say what does the
science really say and what are some
principles that we can hang our hat on
that can guide us in a trajectory that's
doable in the context of our busy lives
very important of course
so we'll put on our miners cap here and
uh
drilled out on this I've heard off
um and he and it starts with a
recognition on on everyone's part how
toxic the standard Western diet has
become and
um if you're especially uh even dabbling
in fast foods at all
every piece of meat you eat is going to
be come with with white bread and sugary
ketchup and hydrogenated oils and and
the the toxic load that comes uh with
with whether it's the peaches or the
burgers or the buffalo wings Etc
and all the diets who are serious about
getting people healthier whether it's
paleo or keto or plant-based whatever
all of us we all we strip away that that
outer hole of toxic we can all agree
that we all agree standard American diet
the fast food diet is bad indeed and
once you do that then that step alone is
a Quantum Leap is a huge Improvement uh
and you reduce a huge load of refined
sugars and uh and fats and foods that
are grossly obesogenic and as a result
uh people and especially the the Paleo
folks strip out the dairy products as
well uh and uh as well as the oils and
when you take out the dairy the oils and
and junk flower products people are
going to lose weight
and the Very Act of losing weight does
good things in most people's bodies and
their lipid profiles get better their
diabetes gets better they feel better
their energy level goes up and so you
see this improve this initial
Improvement in health in in most all of
these dietary Styles and it's enough to
provide very powerful reinforcement I
went paleo boy I lost weight felt good
man it's the diet for me
and and I hear that with the with the
keto folks as well
but as a physician and as a person who
respects the biology of this body that
we have
um I mean no Guerrilla packs its
intestines full of meat two three times
a day like we do
um and having been in the medical game
for so long I have to say wait a minute
granted you see this initial Improvement
but I urge folk do not be seduced by
this Improvement that you're seeing now
what the reality here is you pack that
colon full of meat two three times a day
a day now and you send this surge of
cholesterol and saturated fat and
oxidized meat proteins through the
tissues day after day after day as the
months go by as the years go by this is
a recipe for colon cancer this is a
recipe for artery disease as a recipe
for strokes recipe for dementia recipe
for autoimmune disease from leaky gut
and the problem and and I put this my
slideshow I said medicines become very
segmented Medical Care has become very
fractionated very segmented and the odds
of you seeing the same doctor when you
go back to the clinic are small doctors
move away patient move away and the
point is people
the especially these young docs make
these recommend oh you already eat paleo
you ought to eat keto and then you never
see them again
and I asked those John you make these
recommendations you're going to be
around in 10 years when this guy passes
his first bloody stool from that colon
cancer that your diet spawned you won't
even be around to see it you'll be
around in 12 years this lady's joints
light up from the autoimmune arthritis
that your diet's leaky gut gave her you
won't be around to see it you think
you've done something good for her but
you're going to be around in 15 years
when this guy has a stroke from that
carotid plaque that your diet stirred up
in his arteries are going to be around
to see that and that's my concern as a
seasoned Physicians have been in this
game a while now what what are you
really Brewing up in these patients
colons what are you really Brewing up in
their arteries what are you really
Brewing up in their joints when you
Brewing up in their immune systems and
their prostate glands and their colon
and their breast tissue and and the
folks were making these initial
recommendations don't I say did you
really know what you're doing doctor and
the phrase Do no harm applies to dietary
advice as well and you can really hurt
somebody with the wrong diet and I think
a lot of wrong advice is being given
here we're plant eating creatures we
need to be true to that and you have a
little piece of Flesh once or twice a
week yeah I'd probably get away with it
but but we're not homo carnivorous we're
not flesh-eating apes and uh we're meant
to run on whole plant foods and when we
do that the body gets lean and healthy
and the arteries open up and
inflammation subsides and right the body
has a has the final word on that
quality esteem Dr Neil Bernard quote
some foods are fattening others are
addictive cheese is both if cheese were
any worse it would be Vaseline end quote
while sugar and meat consumption across
the U.S has declined over the past
decade how should we think about dairy
in the standard American diet well Dr
Bernard is here to educate us Dr Bernard
is the president of the Physicians
committee for responsible medicine he's
the author of more than 100 scientific
Publications and 20 books for medical
and lay readers several of which have
been New York Times bestsellers we have
done three in-depth shows with him as
he's a fountain of wisdom and practical
advice in this area and Beyond so here
are a couple clips that I believe you
will find helpful
but to see the truth of it you just have
to look at a country like Japan or China
where these are non-dairy consuming
countries and and they really weren't
eating much meat you know meat was a
kind of a flavoring for the Rice and
Noodles and vegetables and so forth and
and back in 1980 diabetes was rare in
Japan it was between one and five
percent of the adult population uh
McDonald's came in fast food chains came
in meat came in a big way and cheese and
dairy started to follow uh some of the
people in Japan initially and then China
afterward started to say okay we need to
drink milk so that we're strong like
Americans are and what they've gotten is
diabetes rates went up to now 11 to 12
percent in Japan by 1990
diabetes is massive now in China
cardiovascular disease I'm talking heart
disease huge in China and it's not
because of rice and it's not because of
it but it seems that it is meat and the
dairy that is coming in and invading
their diet and yet the conventional
wisdom if you if you if you would ask
you know the average person or perhaps
some of the researchers behind this
study what the you know what the
underlying cause of that that is they're
going to point to processed foods and
sugar most likely right yeah you know
sugar sugar is not health food that's
true that said
um
sugar consumption in the United States
has been falling for almost 20 years it
Rose and I'm talking all sugars together
sugar like cane sugar beet sugar high
fructose corn syrup throw them all in
they rose up until
1999. at that point sugar has been
falling sodas have been falling largely
because of so many Americans are
drinking bottled water or diet soda or
whatever sugar is dropping but obesity
is not falling diabetes is not falling
and to say and once again sugar is not
health food but to say that is the whole
problem
we should all be thin now right that we
should have cure diabetes by now because
sugars has been falling for 20 years but
it but it's not so I'm going to say a
particular amount of blame needs to go
on cheese and especially cheese when you
see an ad for a Wendy's double
cheeseburger or the newest version of
you know the Pizza Hut pizza with the
injected cheese into the crust and all
these sorts of things that actually
there is a relate relationship between
those marketing campaigns and those
products and the influx of government
funding so can you explain that a little
bit because I think a lot of people
would be shocked to hear that by law the
U.S and this has been the case for a
long time the US government by law must
promote American agricultural products
this is something congress in its wisdom
passed a number of years ago and they
promote products regardless of their
health value and it's often in spite of
their health value so they take this pot
of money and they pour it into research
studies and the US government did work
with Wendy's uh with a contract that I
can show you to market the Wendy's
cheddar lovers bacon cheeseburger I'm
not kidding it sold two and a quarter
million pounds of cheese they then
worked with Subway to it which subway
had two sandwiches that didn't have
cheese on them so on contract with the
US government they stuck cheese on those
sandwiches they worked with Pizza Hut to
put an entire pound of cheese on one
serving of pizza they worked at Taco
Bell uh Burger King all the others so
that cheese was promoted for example you
go through the drive-through and you
can't imagine that what they say over
the loudspeaker is going to be the
government speak
welcome to Taco Bell would you like to
try our quesadilla today you know they
don't say you want a strawberry smoothie
you know it's like something cheesy and
so these are all done on contract we got
them through the Freedom of Information
so those talking points are like upsells
that are specifically kind of inserted
into the talking points that that person
at the fast food restaurant is sort of
told this is how you communicate with
the customer yeah that was part of it
the government has supplied advisors to
McDonald's I'm talking about people
going to a McDonald's headquarters and
Advising them on their business
practices I mean don't you think every
computer manufacturer would like to have
the government promoting their products
uh well for some it's it's wrong it
should stop
um but that's where we are we live in a
country which
If This Were a Latin American country
you could imagine drugs it kind of
infusing uh the uh their influence in
the government well here it's
agricultural products doing the same
kind of thing people are promoting
cheese they're saying don't worry about
it has no effect cheese comes from milk
milk comes from a cow who is pregnant
the cows the cows don't give
cows don't give milk at all but they
don't make milk until they have been
impregnated they give birth and then the
milk that their calf was going to get
goes to the dairy
um a cow pregnancy is about nine months
similar to human pregnancy and they are
impregnated every year
so what that means three quarters of
their lives they are pregnant they are
being milked during that time the
estrogen that the cow makes gets into
the milk and it's just it's not much
it's only a trace but the milk is turned
into cheese the the hormones go with the
fat and the average person needs 35
pounds of it every year so researchers
in Rochester New York look looked at men
the men who ate the most cheese had the
worst
sperm counts the worst sperm morphology
the lowest sperm motility in other words
they're because of the estrogen in
contact well that's the theory the
theory is is you're consuming just
little traces of estrogen with your
breakfast
on your egg McMuffin the little cheese
and a little bit more at lunch and quite
a lot of dinner on your pizza and could
those little traces of estrogens matter
now we we had all thought couldn't be
but I got to tell you right here's the
worst um here in California
researchers looked at women who had been
diagnosed with breast cancer
and if you've been if you've had breast
cancer in the past and you were treated
for it your concern is is my cancer
gonna come back of course well the women
who consume the most cheese
had a 49 higher breast cancer mortality
compared to the women who eat the least
and the difference is small the
difference is one daily serving or more
less than a half a serving a day so the
women who eat little or no cheese and
other high-fat dairy products it's
cheese it's butter uh that's where the
hormones go you compare to these low
cheese consumers the ones who eat one or
more servings a day which is not a lot
The increased risk was 49 I'm talking
about risk of dying of your cancer so
again the amounts of hormones are small
but
it raises the question do you want to
feed any kind of dairy
I'm talking about cow's milk goat milk
whatever do you want to feed it to your
six-year-old daughter
or your six-year-old son
or your wife or your husband or yourself
or anybody and my thought is that the
dairy products are this cultural
aberration that has stuck because people
get hooked on it but it has nothing to
do with human biology and we should be
avoiding it
here's a quote outside of an emergency
medical condition that requires an
urgent intervention I have never seen
anything come close to providing the
breadth and depth of benefits that the
plant-based lifestyle offers end quote
that quote is from my next guest Dr
Robert osfeld a summa [ __ ] laude graduate
of the University of Pennsylvania with a
medical degree from Yale and a master's
in epidemiology from Harvard here is a
deep dive into more on his perspective
there's this thing that I like to do
called the Cal scan and
so we've all we're all familiar with CAT
scans you know where they do a big
radiologic picture looking at looking
for a problem in your body whether it's
in the chest or the belly or something
like that well I thought wouldn't it be
cool if we could do a kale scan
which instead of looking for a problem
can look for ways that a plant-based
diet might be beneficial for you
and so I looked through uh some of the
studies and so like we were talking
about a healthier diet doesn't just
point to heart disease so if I could
I'll go through the the Cal scan and
these are things that a plant-based diet
has been Associated not necessarily
unequivocally proven but just other
things pointing in the right direction
associated with improving so first of
all it's been associated with less
mortality less death
and so I'll start from the top down many
of us are on social media on Facebook we
were talking about Facebook just before
so a lot of us saw the ice bucket
challenge well a plant-based diet
elements of that have been associated
with less ALS less stroke less
depression less cognitive decline over
time less Alzheimer's
improve skin complexion less acne in
fact
some investigators suggest that
um
acne is so tightly linked to the Western
diet that it's not actually a Vestige of
teenage angst but actually your body
crying out for help from lack of
nutrition fewer ear infections less
periodontal disease less laryngeal
cancer less heartburn less lung disease
less lung cancer less breast cancer less
heart disease of course less obesity
and the former Surgeon General Dr
Carmona said that this generation will
be the first to live fewer years than
its parents
because of sequally of obesity 70 of our
population is overweight or obese
less high blood pressure we call high
blood pressure the silent killer because
you don't feel it but it can kill you
and it's important that all listeners
get screened for high blood pressure
but now there's a statistic that I read
that blows my mind if you're a 55 year
old adult in the U.S your lifetime risk
of developing heart disease is about 90
percent and that's based on information
from the Framingham art study and every
time I read it I have to reread it it's
just so hot it's unbelievable and but if
you eat a plant-based diet you are
anything but the average adult and you
know for example blueberries can lower
blood pressure
um there's less diabetes there's less
colon cancer less inflammation less
constipation less prostate cancer
associated with less
prostatic hypertrophy and so guys may
recognize that of having to wake up four
or five times at the night during the
night to pee because I can't pee all the
urine out because the prostate's big
improved sexual function in men and
women
and we call of course erectile
dysfunction the canary and the coal mine
for heart disease and getting an
erection is a psychological event it's a
neurologic event and it's a vascular
event
and by the time you have a blockage in
the artery to the penis so the artery to
the penis is smaller than that to the
heart and by the time you have a
blockage in the artery of the penis
giving erectile dysfunction it's
extremely likely you have such blockages
in your heart that just have not yet
clinically manifested right your body's
just trying to tell you that you have
something that you need to deal with
exactly and and the solution is not to
take a small blue pill so that you can
forget about it but rather to do the
opposite which is to heat it and try to
you know take a look at what you're
eating and how you're moving your body
and maybe make some changes
totally agree so when I look at I mean a
couple of observations first of all it's
you know thank you for that rundown I
mean it's so compelling and when I hear
that and I think you know I put it in
context of you know heart diseases
America's number one killer and thinking
of that study and the 90 figure it's
just astonishing and I wonder
why isn't everybody you know doing this
like what is the impediment to people
adopting this and you know that's the
that's the sort of frustration that that
I experienced and kind of what I was
getting at with the people that are out
there trying to you know sort of debunk
The China Study or poo poo the you know
the the the the the the Fantastic
benefits of eating a plant-based diet so
when you see that whether it's on
Facebook or you know some blog on the
Internet or whatever like how do you
you know what do you do what is that how
does that make you feel what do you
think well it's very frustrating to me
um having some background in some of the
science of it and we're ramping up our
research arm of our wellness program too
but
um and but I think that people
oftentimes like to
have the
um the behaviors that they're doing
whether they be good or bad reinforce
people kind of like taking bad habits
yeah exactly right exactly yeah you know
eating that Animal product yeah that's
great for you go for it
right now at least 50 million people
worldwide live with Alzheimer's disease
and rates could exceed 150 million
people by 2050. incredible so how should
we think about brain function on a
plant-based diet can we prevent
neurodegeneration through the choices
that we make around our diet and
lifestyle and what are the best foods to
boost brain function these questions are
best answered by doctors Dean and Aisha
sure the leading neurology team in the
country studying Alzheimer's disease as
their life mission
directors of the Alzheimer's prevention
program at Loma Linda University Medical
Center this amazing husband and wife
team delivered two clips that address
these questions head on
all of the genes involved in Alzheimer's
except for those three percent or three
genes
are all our lifestyle genes
how your lifestyle affects those genes
which means you have control over it
even the most benign studies the ones
that had minimal effect the Mind study
and others mind study just looked at
diet very well done study just a diet
adjustment reduce your risk of
Alzheimer's by 53 wow and that was a
watered down version of the diet we
think is optimal
how how long would you need to be you
know eating and eating in that certain
way leading up to it it varies from
person to person their their background
other things like if they had multiple
head traumas uh childbirth like multiple
variables but in reality if you're on
that diet for several years you
continually reduce your risk like
smoking if you've smoked all your life
and if you come off of smoking come off
of that bacon I've come off of that you
know uh well let's then the more years
you pass I believe in smoking it's after
five years five to seven years yeah
seven years you back to Baseline right
meaning that you're back to the lowest
risk factor
um so the longer you stay on a healthy
lifestyle which is exercise and you know
all the things that we say and
especially if you do all of them the
reason I say all of them was coming back
to our grandparents one of the elements
is cognitive Reserve
or what the term you and I love idea
density you know we say that if we have
a musical band that's going to be called
I idea dancing idea density yes that's a
it's a great great uh concept they both
both our grandparents had immense idea
density and and philosophers think but
they used to come to alzheimer's why the
other elements weren't taken care of
they had diabetes cholesterol high blood
pressure sedentary bad food didn't
exercise philosophers are not supposed
to exercise for some reason but so you
have to do all of it right so we're
going to get into these lifestyle
interventions but before we do that
let's talk about the brain more
generally
um we sort of think of the brain as this
mysterious black box that is unknowable
and something that sits outside of our
body right like there's our body and
then there's our brain and these things
don't really overlap but in truth truth
brain health is really uh it's about
vascular Health in the same way that
heart health is right like we're dealing
with I don't know how many zillions of
of you know arteries that are going into
going into the brain you know you know
putting things in your brain and taking
them out Etc
um and and when you think about you know
heart disease we we all know we're
trying to not have plaque in Our
arteries and keep those pipes running
clean and brain health is really not
that different is it that's very true
you put it beautifully
um when you look at the brain it's about
three pounds like jello it's like hard
Jello when you hold it in your hands and
it's about two percent of your body's
energy and when you look at the tissues
and the vessels there are the same
vessels that are in your heart and in
your kidney and your body I'm a vascular
neurologist so I teach a lot of anatomy
to medical students and residents about
the vasculature of the brain but
basically you know you have artery
shooting from your heart going through
the neck there's two major ones in the
front the carotid arteries and the
vertebral arteries and these are the
major vessels that take blood to your
brain and there's just branching of
these arteries and somebody actually
calculated this but if you put the
vessels uh in your brain end to end it
would span about 400 miles so just
imagine all of these tiny hairline
arteries taking in oxygen and nutrients
to these susceptible areas of the brain
for this this incredible organ to
function and at any moment our brain as
little and as small as it is it can
consume up to 25 percent of the body's
energy so just imagine the amount of
work that it does and if we don't
address vascular health and if we don't
really take care of it it will succumb
to disease you know we we always say in
our cardiologist plans don't really like
that but we say the rest of the body is
there to carry the brain
um and it essentially comes down to the
same pathological processes that affect
the brain that also affects the heart
the kidneys and the other systems as
well so let's look at the foods that
that are beneficial like when you look
at the the plant kingdom what stands out
you know I know we want to stay away
from quote unquote superfoods but some
foods are better than others like what
should people
focus on who are trying to enhance their
brain health I think
to give a quick version of of what's out
there as far as data is concerned
consumption of green leafy vegetables
for example seems to be very helpful and
it's like unanimous results that you see
across different studies
berries such as blueberries and
strawberries they stand out whether it's
the mine diet or the Mediterranean diet
or even in the Adventist Health study
because these are foods that have the
highest amount of anti-inflammatories
spices like turmeric we actually wrote a
paper and when we were in Cedar Sinai
where we gave our patients high doses of
turmeric and turmeric seems to have the
curcumin part of it is a very potent
anti-inflammatory and it seems to bind
with amyloid which is the bad protein
associated with Alzheimer's disease and
it it removes it oh wow we measured the
amount of amyloid the amyloid load in
retina and after giving them high
amounts of turmeric we actually saw the
turmeric binding to the amyloid in the
retina just really really interesting
and we're learning more about it as we
speak
um and uh yeah so high fiber green leafy
vegetables and berries and spices
especially turmeric seems to be on the
top she and flaxseed and flaxseed which
are amazing sources of plant-based
omega-3 fatty acids hemp seeds nuts like
walnuts whole grains
they seem to have the right kind of
micronutrients whether it's thiamin or
riboflavin or folic acid bound
beautifully synergistically supporting
each other's absorbance and
bioavailability they all tend to reduce
the risk for Alzheimer's disease and we
have studies that have looked at
individual foods and risk of Alzheimer's
disease and the combination thereof too
are there any plant foods to avoid
I would say the plant foods to avoid
seems to be coconut oil I know that that
again is a controversial area and a lot
of people are just yeah they love
coconut I know I'm sorry but you know I
I love that used to be the thing coconut
oil for brain health yeah I know and
unfortunately the data was pretty flawed
when it came out it was based um on a
couple of uh case studies and it as it
happened somebody gave their loved ones
some coconut oil and they seemed to
improve but then there was no long-term
follow-up but coconut oil and I'm happy
to say that there's consensus on it and
you know as a scientist I want to look
at different sources of data whether
it's clinical trials whether it's
epidemiological whether it's case series
and there's consensus between different
scientists and doctors and Physicians
that coconut oil seems to increase our
bad cholesterol LDL which can result
into vascular damage and the reason
being is because coconut oil is one of
the few plant oils that that is more
than 90 saturated fats and so is palm
oil
Dr Joel Khan is an esteemed cardiologist
who's authored hundreds of articles on
heart disease and has performed
thousands of cardiac procedures
Dr Khan was a feature contributor to the
documentary what the health and has been
a guest on this show three times I asked
Dr Khan what the results might be if we
were to introduce a fasting mimicking
process to a plant-based diet what he
shares is astounding and further
illustrates the unique power and healing
capabilities of plant Foods Dr Khan
references research by longevity experts
like Dr Walter Longo and he brilliantly
summarizes for us the benefits of adding
intermittent fasting to a plant-based
lifestyle so
take a listen
could we mimic fasting but still eat
provocative crazy idea could we create a
diet that doesn't have the components
that food causes that accelerates the
mtor pathway the PK pathway these
Pathways that accelerate aging and
um uh destruction of cells can we create
a diet that lets you eat some and can we
actually still benefit from what fasting
seems to do which is a accelerate a
process a fancy word autophagy the
clearing of damaged cells to allow them
to function better that process real
quickly they won the Nobel Prize last
year autophagy is like the hot mutton
right now of anti-aging that if you
eliminate it every case of heart disease
cancer and diabetes would extend human
life by 13 years if we could end damage
to cells and improve the efficiency of
autophagy to take your cells that are
aging and restore them to a youthful
state would extend human life by 30
years so the research is going now in
this anti-aging world and he created
bottom line to die diet that five days
in a row of in The Human Experience 800
calories a day of a plant-based diet low
in sugar and low in protein but
containing Whole Food fats like olives
and nuts and containing moderate complex
carbohydrates so that the carbohydrate
calorie loads about 35 percent that he
found in animal models and in a study
published February 2017 and 100 humans
that you could see the responses you get
with a complete fast but you don't have
the pain of a complete fast you don't
have the risk of a complete fast he
called that and patented that fmd
fasting mimicking diets
um and he has shown that not only do
they favor losing visceral fat around
your belly which is what so many people
are doing 10-day belly bloats five days
in a row in a month and you can do it as
many months in a row as you can tolerate
and all and we're talking about eating a
nut bar for breakfast we're talking
about eating soup and kale crackers for
lunch we're talking about eating soup
um and occasionally a little cacao bar
for dinner these actually come
pre-packaged in a startup that he uh
engaged in with the University of
Southern California that doing that five
days in a row activates these Primal
Pathways that actually not only favor
improved metabolism losing visceral fat
you don't lose muscle mass which is
fantastic but you actually lower igf-1
levels which is one of the goals and
lastly you actually create a flood of
stem cells from your bone marrow into
your bloodstream stem cells that people
are going to Tijuana and paying a ton of
money for that will go to injured and
damaged parts of your body and clear out
damaged cells so there's data now in
animals and some human data that
multiple sclerosis may be responsive to
a five-day fasting mimicking diet of
plants low in sugar low in fat that
actually brain growth occurs in animal
models and right now cognition is being
studied in Italy using Dr Longo's
five-day fasting diet in addition to
just weight loss that cancer patients
it's called chemo leave it's a product
they've developed and not released it
it's being studied at the Mayo Clinic in
other places that if you're getting
chemotherapy and you do this fasting
mimicking diet and use plants and use
low sugar low fat you actually get a
better kill rate for the chemotherapy
and you get less side effects profound
data athletes are being studied in
Verona Italy right now to see if this
enhances performance if it will enhance
recovery and allow you to go back and do
the next athletic event with more
success so several hundred worldwide
studies using this exact model I would
describe it it's a plant-based cyclical
ketogenic diet cyclical because it's
five days a month and it's plants so
it's not the extreme of what you're
seeing on the blogosphere it's the
plants and the plant proteins that don't
seem to activate aging like animal-based
protein and it's 800 calories a day it's
not water fasting so there are people
who shouldn't do it underweight people
pregnant people brittle diabetics
brittle heart patients 800 calories a
day I've done it seven of the last 11
months I'm down 25 pounds wow I bound
this energy my labs show Improvement my
blood pressure shows Improvement I have
dozens of patients who have had the same
experience and you know what do you do
with a heavy vegan who's really doing it
right you've got to change your
metabolism and this is one of the hacks
that might you know allow our movements
one to have the scientific basis is say
we're in the right sector of the food
plate and two to actually help people
get more out of it than they're getting
because not everybody eating a whole
food plant-based diet with oil without
oil is going to achieve their optimal
blood pressure blood sugar and weight
and we need more tools and this is one
of the tools
the American College of Cardiology a
more than 50 000 member medical society
is the professional home base for the
entire Cardiology profession and five
years ago I sat down with his former
president Dr Kim Williams Dr Williams is
one of the most inspiring the most
intelligent and pioneering leaders in
the growing movement to modernize how we
think treat and hopefully prevent heart
disease which is still our most onerous
threat to human health one out of three
people in America dies from
cardiovascular disease it is and remains
our number one killer and it's still the
number one killer of cardiologists
plants are the solution and no master
class would be complete without the
words of those who know best so in his
own words here is Dr Kim Williams
last year was the first time in 40 years
that cardiovascular disease deaths in
the country went up and that is just
something that we just can't abide by
and you know they've you we are we're
always bragging about this decreasing
curve about 50 over 40 years in
cardiovascular mortality and it's bypass
surgery and statins and beta bloggers
and eights and there were all these
medications for heart failure and
decreasing sudden death because we put
in defibrillators that shock people when
they when they have a fatal arrhythmia
and they come back to life and we were
so proud of all the stuff and then the
American population somehow is
overcoming an end run around this no
matter what you do exactly yeah and when
the CDC put those numbers out there they
said it was obesity and diabetes that's
driving it and that's a nutrition and so
it all the fundamental issue that we've
been dealing with for the last so many
years is really at the core of all we do
and it will uproot and and undo any
success that we can do with devices and
medications yeah it's got to be a shift
in priorities and focus because it is
amazing to reduce by 50 percent the
mortality rate of people who are
suffering from heart disease as a result
of all this amazing science and
technology
but if that comes at the cost of really
addressing the fact that the incidence
of people who are you know you know
becoming patients in the first place
then you're you're waging a losing War
right ultimately yeah everyone's going
to get older and they're going to pass
away at some point wouldn't it be nice
if we were as healthy as possible until
that happened and not have these chronic
diseases that are completely avoidable
by uh by lifestyle a lot of the
Publications weren't out there in 2003
but the data's out there now animal
protein is bad for you heme iron is bad
for you the cholesterol the igf-1 and
the animal protein this is this is all
science and so the difference is now I
read it now the other major controversy
which I probably shouldn't repeat one
more time but I guess I'm gonna do it
was making that comment which was
completely half joking but I was making
a statement
about cardiovascular research and the
fact that nutrition research is
typically in the American journal of
clinical nutrition it's not in the
general American College of Cardiology
so much and so it's not in front of the
cardiologists and so I made that
statement
again more than half joking the
statement that that
um yeah why don't you you say it right
two kinds of cardiologists vegans and
those who haven't read the data now I
got you into a little trouble yeah it
did well the interesting part is that uh
you know it's with like like they say if
you take the text out of the context
then all you're left with is the con and
so people were misunderstanding I
thought I'm throwing all my colleagues
under the bus when I'm really claiming
or asking for more research more review
articles more you know more data to go
into Cardiology journals so that people
are actually seeing it then it can
influence their their lives and their
patients
but then
two things started to happen one is uh
the you know the pushback from that uh
was actually I think most people
understood that I was saying that if
they know me at all that they don't know
me they wouldn't say anything to me if
they did know me they knew that I was
you know saying that in a joke in a
jocular manner but there were some
people who took it seriously
particularly at rush where you know I'm
the chief of Cardiology and we now have
uh you know nine vegan cardiologists
people looked at the data and they saw
that you know this is probably something
I shouldn't be eating and they've
they've uh changed their own lifestyle
which is wonderful because it gives us a
good Cadre of people who work on
prevention the other thing that happened
though uh I have to say is that um I
spent six years on the American Board of
internal medicine doing the Cardiology
exam and then the ACC
leadership position folks so I'm seeing
a lot of cardiologists than my time at
the American side of nuclear Cardiology
I was president
12 years ago
each one of those organizations has had
some luminary person who died of heart
disease
and I'm kind of saying that's where we
really need to start that is in order to
fix the population through all the
powers of our Acca guidelines the the
people who are actually getting that
data out there and putting it in the
hands of patients and the prescriptions
and telling people what how they should
live is Cardiology so at this point I've
had enough of the sudden cardiac deaths
I'm actually my my new goal is to not
retire until the leading cause of death
and cardiologists is no longer heart
diseased and so it's amazing that it it
precipitates at that level amongst you
know amongst your peers you know on some
level it's like you can't transmit
something you haven't got like if you're
if you're not living this life in a
certain way where you're you know or
you're an embodiment of the message that
you're promoting that's inherently
problematic right so I it really has
affected me in terms of the the guilt
when one of my friends would pass away
you know they knew that I was eating
different I I ate with them they knew
that I was getting different and did I
say anything and did I say it loud
enough and so now any quip that I can
come up with that gets on my face today
or Twitter or I'm fine with I'll take
the backlash if it's going to save some
of my colleagues lives ultimately that
will help our country that will help uh
reduce this this terrible epidemic of
heart disease even if it makes me
unpopular nutrition is the most
important decision that we can make if
we could change one thing
it would be to have heart-healthy
information coming out and and have that
be a real definition
um and so for the individual patient
finding out where they are and seeing
what are the elements that are going to
create more more and more diseases uh
similar to what brought them to my
office in the first place and uh and I I
understand that this this is not Primary
Care this is not Family Practice not you
know these are people who already have
heart disease when they're seeing me and
so I have a little easier job because
they're already motivated the fact that
they're in my office means that they're
motivated to try to make some kind of
change they're expecting to come out of
there with something different that's
going to change their outcome not every
physician has that
Advantage but it's something that we all
should take advantage of because you
know almost everyone has had a
family member
who suffers from heart disease or his
hand heart disease or has sudden cardiac
death and so just trying to get them to
understand that there is a relationship
between your lifestyle
and your outcome just make that
connection if we could do that we would
all be so so much better off right
a whole food plant-based lifestyle is
also a recalibration of our relationship
with things like salt oil and sugar
modern food additives that Spike
dopamine and can create all sorts of
problems so how do we reframe our often
dysfunctional relationship with food so
that we are never again a victim of
addictive behaviors well taking us
through this complex issue is Dr Alan
goldhammer co-author of the book the
pleasure trap here's an excerpt from one
of our all-time most popular episodes
the social roadblocks to health are
probably some of the limiting factors I
think that's probably true in all
addiction though you know one of the
challenges for people with alcohol is
oftentimes the social consequences yes
of not participating and this is
definitely true with food we've built so
much of our social interaction around
food that even even if you're looking to
just modify the type of food you eat it
can be very upsetting for people and
they can get really defensive about it
right so let's talk a little bit more
about the pleasure trap specifically
what that is you co-authored this book
seminal work with with Doug Lyle I've
seen his Ted talk I've seen him give his
presentation many times on this subject
and that really you know elucidates this
dysfunctional relationship with food and
and why it is from an evolutionary and
psychological perspective well you know
there's this idea of dopamine is a
neurochemical associated with pleasure
and there's two behaviors critical for
human being survival and that is food
insects you have to get enough to eat in
order to be able to sustain yourself and
you have to engage in enough sexual
behavior so that you can pass on your
genes and the whole process can start
over again so it's not surprising that
food insects are heavily reinforced and
the way the body the brain reinforces
the body's behavior is by rewarding us
with dopamine which is the neurochemical
associated with pleasure so the more
dopamine the more pleasure the more dope
mean the better the food tastes and so
you react to food in response to largely
caloric density a higher the caloric
density the more valuable it is in this
environment is scarcity in which we
evolved and so the higher caloric
density foods are tend to be more
reinforced more dopamine better tasting
so what we've done as humans we're
Innovative creatures we said oh if a
little good A lot's better let's figure
out a way to make the food taste even
more special by increasing its caloric
density and we do that by adding things
like oil and sugar to the food
and as a consequence we like it better
and if that's what you get used to
eating that's all you like and
eventually people get to the point they
really don't like the taste of simple
whole Natural Foods anymore because this
hyper drug-like stimulating effect of
the more concentrated Foods is more
appealing so we literally become
addicted for example if you want to
neuroadapt to a lower salt or lower fat
diet it actually takes time in order to
the body to go through that adaptation
right we can speed it up with fasting
but the bottom line is there's a period
of adaptation where food doesn't taste
good if you eat Whole Foods and you're
used to eating highly processed foods
it's not that appealing now over time
you adapt and then the body gets to the
point where you like the simpler Foods
again yeah people have a hard time
believing that you adapt there's this
baked in assumption that
you're you're you're you're you're just
gonna you're looking you're staring down
the pipeline of a lifetime of drab foods
that are unappealing and you're just
gonna have to tolerate it um we know
there's a literature on this though with
for example sodium uh people use on high
sodium diet it takes about a month on a
low sleeping diet for the average person
to neurodapt to a lower salt diet you
know with fat it takes almost three
months wow it takes three months on a
lower fat diet before that satiety
mechanism that's used to being kicked in
by the higher caloric density fat begins
to adapt and you'll feel satisfied on a
lower uh density Foods so the fruits the
vegetables or grains of goods you will
now feel satisfied whereas initially you
don't because you're used to being
satiated with these high fat uh this
high fat intake and that that can take
months and so it's a problem if you say
to a person well look you're going to
eat this new diet you're going to feel
like crap and you're not gonna like it
and but it'll only be a few months right
adherence may be lagging whereas if you
can make that process happened more
quickly the ability to get people to
make dietary changes speeds up and
that's what we found with fasting and
sometimes that's a way of getting people
to the point where good food tastes good
more quickly yeah what we're encouraging
people to do is a really radical
departure from what they're currently
doing but that's to adopt a whole plant
food diet
that's free of this added chemicals free
of the salt oil and sugar and what
you're left with is things like fruits
and vegetables raw or cooked minimally
processed grains beans nuts and seeds
but you don't have the meat fish Val
eggs dairy products oil salt sugar and
highly processed fractionated foods that
make up the majority of the people's
diet in industrialized society and it's
that diet that makes them fat and sick
and develop the diseases of dietary
excess and that what makes you
vulnerable to con infectious disease you
know when you look at what are the
vulnerabilities about why do some people
get an influenza or a covid or an
infectious disease and you know they
recover they survive they have minimal
consequence other people it's
devastating or deadly well if you look
at the risk factors associated with what
makes people vulnerable to these
diseases as well as the disease the
chronic diseases the heart disease the
cancer the stroke it's the same
metabolic syndrome in all of its
associations it's the same obesity and
diabetes and high blood pressure and all
the consequences of dietary excess these
are reversible
and preventable conditions people don't
have to have these conditions and even
if they have them they can largely
reverse them by taking responsibility to
control what they put in their mouth
okay we did it I hope this master class
was valuable and actionable for you and
as we conclude this deep dive into the
plant powered lifestyle I want to
acknowledge that in some cases for a
variety of reasons not everyone can or
will make the pivot to a 100 percent
Whole Food plant-based lifestyle and if
that is you you'll find no judgment here
what I would like to submit however is
that intentionally creating small goals
for yourself toward moving away from an
ultra processed food-based diet and
adding more plant foods to your plate
could be transformative for your health
for your energy for your performance and
for your longevity that has been my
experience and that has been the
testimony of the experts collected here
today
it's my hope that this master class has
helped you on your journey or could be
used as a way of helping a loved one and
if you have been personally inspired
please consider visiting the full
in-depth conversations with these
esteemed guests you can find links to
each episode posted in the YouTube
description or in the show notes at
richroll.com
thank you for listening thank you for
watching and please know that I'm
wishing all of you the greatest life
possible powered by as many plants as
possible
until next time peace thanks
[Music]